you have a productivity hack an easy
productivity hack instead of spending
time getting in the mood to work just
start working confront the work people
think they need perfect conditions to
start when in reality starting is the
perfect condition
I'm married to that
I love that
because
if you think like I you know I obviously
am somebody who always wants to optimize
how much work I do per unit of time and
so I I was you know there was definitely
times earlier in my life I was really
romanticized by these like very
extensive morning routines and
supplement rituals and like all this
stuff of mental masturbation around the
work that need to be done but when I
looked at two hours later and nothing
had actually gotten done
the moment you begin working
is when your output per unit of time
goes up
and so that makes beginning the single
greatest hack that you can have for
everything else that you do in work
because things when you start working
you start getting in the mood to work
right like everything else is
procrastinating around the work that you
think you should do but like I have
noticed for me at least I have these I
have some big mental tasks you know what
I mean like big content piece or big
thing that you need like you know it's
going to take real mental effort it
takes me like five minutes of actually
being in it to then get a little bit of
a lay of the land to then get into it
but I used to take hours to delay to
start the first five minutes and so my
time compression of when I thought I
should start doing something and when I
started doing it over time it's just
compressed to the point where it's like
the moment I think that I need to start
doing it sometimes I just start it
because then what happens I get this
open loop and so rather than complete
work at like because a lot of people
were like I want to complete it at this
really nice clean Point stop halfway
through the sentence because it'll drive
you mad that's the zygonic effect in
full work do you know this story
psygonic oh wow this is way more than I
did that's why you shut up that's but
you're leveraging here so um the zygonic
effect was a study originally done on
servers in restaurants and they realized
you've ever been at a restaurant and a
server comes up and stands with their
hands behind the back and go what would
you like tonight sir and you say I'll
have the lobster roll and a glass of red
wine and a blah blah and you're like
this motherfucker's not he hasn't got a
pen or a pad of paper he's crazy and
then they go off and what they realized
was servers in restaurants
were unbelievably good at being able to
recall exactly what a table's order was
while that table's order was still open
so uh guys in table 16 uh they want to
swap the PS out for a little bit of
extra rice and they're doing this thing
as soon as the table was closed they
couldn't remember anything so this is an
open loop closed loop system and it's
built into the brain
the brain abhors an open loop it's the
same reason why Netflix Cliffhangers at
the end of every episode guarantee that
you'll watch the next one because you
can't bear the fact there's even novels
in the dark romance genre that make
guarantees that there won't be
Cliffhangers they make they put it on
the front or the back of the book and
they say no Cliffhanger is guaranteed
which is
people have so much distaste for it that
it's a selling point that you get the
closure at the end of it and finishing
halfway through a sentence
reduces the activation energy required
to begin that sentence the next day and
it keeps it in your mind too overnight
so I think yeah whether you've stumbled
on it or whether you knew about it
you've managed to leverage a pretty
powerful piece of psychology there sick
going back to the work thing uh another
one from you that I absolutely adore it
just takes work shitloads and shitloads
of work every time I try and dress it up
or cut a corner I get brutally reminded
the work just needs doing the work
doesn't care who you are it just cares
that it gets done
I'm actually going to reverse quote
David Goggins on this one
but uh I love this quote that he has
which he says there's no shortcuts for
you David or there's no shortcuts for
you Goggins I heard him say that and I
just love that as a refrain which is
that a lot of people look for a shortcut
but the idea that you say like they're
not for you you don't get to use them
you are immune to shortcuts
I just love it because then it just
further shortcuts the path to the work
that needs to get done
and I wrote that tweet on my I don't
know 11th run of this presentation that
I'm doing because that's a recent one
yeah and so I was it was like 11 o'clock
at night and so right now I'm working
triple shifts which is not common for me
I usually do two not three
um so for me in normal work day is like
I wake up I start working at you know
six or seven and then I go until about
six ish so it's like 10 to 12 really
concentrated of hours work and that I
can do six and a half days a week I
usually take Saturday afternoons off
um and it's really just because at that
point I can't work anymore in My Brain
Stew and then I I get my one half day
and then I'm good to go and I'm rearing
to kick on you know to work on Sundays
my triple shift is I get I go to dinner
and I come back at 7 30 and then I work
from 7 30 until 11 30 or 1 or whatever
right
and when I'm putting in triple shifts is
when I know I'm like really gassing it
um and that's that's when I'm like
repeatedly doing 16 17 a day of actual
productive work and
I I hear the same thoughts that everyone
does which is like it's not going to
matter like it's fine you've like it's
good enough like I hate that like it it
makes me sick to even say that right
because the thing that I like David
Goggins right he's got like there's no
shortcuts for you I would say the one
that I have two that are like my
internal ones one that is probably the
most common is I will do what is
required
and
this work needs doing
and there's just no way around it and
it's just it's just looking at the face
of the work and it's like smiling back
at me like
no one else is going to do it
um and like
I love that one like when we're
recording content in the early days
we're doing like 100 shorts every time
we did it and it was direct to camera
and it was the only time I could fit it
in with all the portfolio stuff that
we're doing
and so I was it was always like I will
do what's required and that's been a
really helpful refrain for me when I'm
confronted with especially when you know
what needs to get done and the second
one is
but I'll know
and so like even if it does go well and
even if everyone else says it's great
but I'll know
and it'll then rob me of all of the joy
of all of those moments in that
experience because I'll know that I
could have done better and the thing is
it's like to to quote myself from
earlier like I've never regretted
working harder
ever not once and some people like on
your deathbed you're like no because I
lived every moment of my day doing what
I wanted to do and I remember I had a
boss when I um my first boss after
college
she said this thing I had had a
particularly good weekend and she said
I'm pretty sure happiness is stringing
as many of those days in a row as you
possibly can
and although I hated the job that piece
of advice has actually been probably
what I has been my blueprint for how to
live which is like my birthday looks the
same as my Tuesdays which looks the same
as my Sundays you know what the original
name
pool for this podcast was this is the
only time in history I've done branding
my entire adult life and with club
nights all you're doing is coming up
with Brands
Paradiso oh it's it's tropical there'll
be a flamingo skint oh it's a cheap
night it's for people to get fingered in
the corner like it's we all I did was
branding right I was The Branding guy
I'm pretty good at copywriting all I did
was Brandy the one time I've had divine
inspiration three in the morning wake up
with the name was Modern wisdom the one
time out of every business every night
every brand I've ever come up with that
was the one time but on the list of the
others mind mind and matter was one of
them but the other one was a quote from
Tim Ferriss which was called crushing a
Tuesday
and he said that what you should aim for
in life is for your average Tuesday
not the spectacular one-time private jet
with the friends to go for the whatever
whatever not the UFC power slap launch
party
staring at the back of Dan bilzerian's
dirty mullet like
not that you want your average Tuesday
to look the way that you want most of
your life to do and when I think about
the days that I look back on at the end
of my day and think like today was a
good day invariably it's the same few
things it's I worked very hard on
something that I felt was worth doing
I worked out and I spent time with
people that I enjoy being around
if I do those three things I had a good
day and so that's been my you know
Alex's simple blueprint for doing things
and I think the point that you were
making earlier I think it's worth
hitting on again which is just that like
most people's definition of work is a
negative one which is why they abhor it
which is also why they misunderstand so
many people who quote I'll say quote
here are successful or ahead of them or
whatever is that both people one person
says the word work and the other person
hears the word pain and so
the first step to like becoming more
successful is understanding the language
that the people who are successful are
using they're actually defining the word
differently and so
whatever that thing is that you actually
enjoy doing where you lose track of time
when you're in it even if it's
challenging but usually it is
challenging right like it's not easy
because then it's boring right which is
also why the uncertainty thing is so key
right to not knowing if it's gonna if
it's gonna work or not you are going to
work though either way
um
is that the people who are quote
addicted to work make it easy to be
addicted to work because they
do things worth doing
and I think a lot of it is coming down
to making sure that you take the few
precious seconds that we have to do the
few things that are worth doing for the
rest of your life we'll get back to
talking to Alex in one minute but first
I need to tell you about the number one
e-commerce platform Shopify when I was a
nightclub promoter in the UK I started
an online apparel brand with no
experience no coding ability no
marketing background no inventory
management and after a ton of research I
decided on Shopify Shopify is the
Commerce platform revolutionizing
millions of businesses worldwide you've
probably already heard of it in fact a
lot of your favorite Brands still use
Shopify including gymshark one of the
biggest sports apparel brands on the
planet Shopify is the only tool you need
to start run and grow your online
business without the struggle what I
loved about Shopify was that as we added
in new lines and different verticals it
grew with the business it required zero
experience every single time there was a
problem I was able to sort it myself
that's how simple it is there is a one
dollar per month trial period that you
can sign up for right now with the link
in the description or by going to
shopify.com Modern wisdom or lowercase
that's shopify.com modern wisdom to take
your business to the next level today
oh hey thanks for tuning in if you
enjoyed that clip then press here for
the full three hour podcast with Alex
go on
press it
foreign